Okay, enough about analyze. Let's talk about parallelize.
We're going to use a running example to illustrate the concepts that we'll go through
over the rest of this unit. And that example is matrix transpose.
It's a very simple algorithm that still has enough meat in it
to illustrate a lot of the points we want to bring up.
Matrix transpose just takes some matrix and exchanges the rows and columns.
So a particular element in this row, for example, would have coordinate a,b.
So its i coordinate is a, its j coordinate is b,
and its new i coordinate in the transpose matrix will be b,
and its new j coordinate will be a. Pretty simple.
To make our code even simpler, we're actually going to restrict ourselves to square matrices.
You'll remember that this came up all the way back in Unit 2
as a really common parallel communication pattern.
So transposing a matrix or doing some equivalent operation on an array
or an image or a structure of arrays, this comes up literally all the time.
So even though it's a simple example, as you'll see,
there's a lot of opportunity to optimize it and it's a really important one.